you know whatever those Tyler Perry
movies come out I usually get messages
from some people like dude why don't you
ever review Tyler Perry movies okay so
now I will Madea Goes to Alex cross
so in Alex cross Tyler Perry plays Alex
Crosby you don't know who that is it's
Morgan Freeman's character from a long
came a spider and kiss the girls yeah so
I guess to some people when they think
oh we need young Morgan Freeman the guy
they think of is Tyler Perry is what it
is so Matthew Fox is his lunatic he's
like just really insane dude he tortures
and kills people so Alex Cross and his
crew his crew consisting of Eddie burns
and Rachel Nichols you know Rachel
Nichols she's like the hot chick and
whatever she's in any movie she's in
where someone's like oh yeah that hot
chick they're talking about her she's up
there trying to stop Matthew Fox all
right Tyler Perry being Alex Cross this
is what they establish Alex Cross is
he's this guy he uses logic reason and
deduction to psychologically get in
people's heads you know those guys are
like oh you have a stain on your shirt
that means you were at this place your
hand smells like gasoline which means
you stopped to fill up the car so he's
pretty much like a Sherlock Holmes or
dr. house but you know the black dude
version in other words he's pretty much
like Idris Elba from the show Luther in
which I am going to bring up the most
logical question on the face of the
earth why didn't they cast a dress Elba
as Alex Cross the dude would have been
perfect I have to assume someone
approached Idris Elba and he was like
yeah now for me if nobody even
considered a dress Elba's Alex Cross
someone got fired I'm not gonna [ __ ]
about that too much although that would
have been the logical choice we're gonna
move on with this review ultimately the
premise of Alex Cross is you have a bad
guy killing people and Alex Cross and
his crew need to stop them yeah sounds
pretty generic discussed the movie is
pretty much generic I was watching the
movie and I was like I feel like I'm
watching an episode of a TV show and to
its credit Alex Cross would not have
been a bad pilot episode for an Alex
Cross TV show I have to assume that was
the plan like they wrote out this pilot
episode and someone was like well we can
make an Alex Cross TV show and it'll get
cancelled in eight episodes like most
any other cop show that comes on
prime-time television or we can take the
pilot episode give it a theatrical
release and try to get our money that
way it was like when you watch Star Trek
insurrection you know that Star Trek
movie in which there's that planet and
everyone stays young in Sulli area from
amadeus as the bad guy and all
good [ __ ] and you're watching it you're
like this feels like an episode of the
TV show it shouldn't feel like that when
you're watching a movie but that's just
what you feel like that is that looks
crossed a thing that worked in this
movie for me was Matthew Fox I like
Matthew Fox I think he's a good actor I
thought he was really good in the show
lost so when he gets screen time and he
gets to play a really crazy dude I like
that and his character in this movie
you're like yeah you're out of your mind
he's got the crazy eyes you know the way
he enunciates his words you're like yeah
you're a crazy bastard any movie like
this that has a really crazy bad guy I'm
down with that he would have been a
great crazy bad guy in the pilot episode
of a TV show which this movie was
probably written to be then the action
scene happens at the end and Tyler Perry
is fighting Matthew Fox and I'm you're
gonna hear this from everybody who saw
the movie it is arguably if not
definitely the worst shaky-cam
I've experienced in my life I think
there are about two people on the face
of the planet who can actually film
shaky-cam action sequences in a way that
actually enhances the experience whoever
this cameraman was he's not one of those
people it was just so shaky the guy is
just doing it he's just moving do you
know the Italian dude in Boardwalk
Empire the chick had the belt around his
neck and he's doing a choking stroke
session imagine him filming an action
sequence while that is happening that is
what it was like that's what I thought
of weird that I thought of that doesn't
make it any less true I didn't hate the
movie it just it says average and
generic as cop movie can possibly be you
care about the characters you do not
just say that looks cross it's alright
but you're not gonna remember in t-minus
one day yep already forgot and I can't
even say Tyler Perry was bad in this
movie he just was there in this movie he
existed when your lead actor whose
character is the name of the movie title
is that forgettable that's that's that's
not good I see your favorite cops
suspense drama cool movie a good one we
got to name some good ones here what's
your favorite whatever it is comment
below let me know and as always if you
liked what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
you
[Music]